hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back because I almost said
the evil in it
so I'm saying that but not right now
still got a lot of other things to worry
we're coming in on the last 1,000 levels
for the last
pretty soon we're gonna reach a point
where we get to the end of this game cuz
I'm pretty sure it ends at a thousand
not a hundred percent on that one we
stop here although I don't hear the
splits watching anymore I'm not gonna
take many chances I want to make sure
that I'm gonna get out of this alive cuz
if I have to go back at this point oh
god finally we're out of it
okay so there might be something in 9:50
and then it might be just all the way to
a thousand who knows with these things
there could always be more douchiness
damn it yes okay alright yeah as I say
there can always be more douchiness in
these games I have no idea what it is by
now I hope I'm I think by the time
you've seen this I might be actually be
back from VidCon so there's my first
time at VidCon and I have no idea what
to expect
all I know is that I had two panels
while I was there and then doing some
other stuff I don't know I don't really
have time to think about that right now
actually got a whole lot of other things
on my mind that look nice that could
have had a death trap but who knows I
just realized that I never had a mentor
for oh I know this we already realized
that thank you
previously what's with the new sounds
yes some meaning to that maybe
all right 951 without a hit so I guess
we're all the way going to a thousand
which means that something big is gonna
happen out of a thousand maybe a final
showdown with spooky before all this
actually goes down no well that's a
different sound I don't know no no not
at the goopy goop
none of the goo be good I don't like the
goofy goo oh man I'm just I'm waiting
for some I'm waiting for something
horrible to jump out at me and happen
because I know we're approaching the end
here and I know then I'm gonna get to
the end but I mean it's just like you
know I'm this far they're bound to have
another trick up their sleeve is what
I'm trying to say
the Kansas let me go that easily I mean
they could it'd be really nice if they
did but I have a giant fill but they're
not going to something his hands down
something's gonna have something has to
happen oh not my I'm not Mother Brain I
don't worry about that I don't care
about that if this turns out to be a big
anti climactic finish I don't know if
I'm gonna be thrilled or mad okay that's
a thing oh I know what you're gonna do I
know what you're gonna do no are you
gonna do
[ __ ] why am I here wow how did I get
here okay hi I'm back here why what the
hell what what is it going on okay cool
all right great why my new is gonna have
some douchiness up its sleep you your
new okay cup of coffee I don't need one
like this bad stuffs after bad salsa
approaching the final numbers here final
numbers and I don't think it's gonna
like it I don't think it's gonna like me
when I'm getting to the end of it
that was another tone change I still
don't know why transition from that one
map to the next I was literally I didn't
even go through a door it just warped me
to there I don't even know if the room
number went up and then happening almost
there Oh
988 oh crap we're getting there
we're gonna get there oh one oh crap no
no no no
oh oh okay I can't see anything
don't do nothing what is this what is it
baloney what is this my lucky day tube
food supply depleted water supply of 30%
metal Alkatiri reading what holy a day -
dad dad this is the same point cuz the
last is actually gonna be really
difficult to get through bed yes I
somehow bad yes okay what do you get oh
here we go
not this oh come on
why this nothing a whole lot of nothing
crap what the hell no I don't believe it
I don't believe it for a second I'll
believe it
Oh
[Music]
oh crap hi sure did what oh okay okay
cool all right then let's see what
happens Oh what is this what is this
baloney what is this what is this
okay thank you why what does that mean
oh crap okay
731 is that important
I can't sprint anymore so don't like
that what is that what why what what Oh
okay
like that
fight me bro
until you at self
okay whoa that's not good
can see anything did he get the red
jelly off my face please
anything
okay oh my god
okay I get it
I need to hit him with the nose and its
own attack or something I didn't know
that it was the fireball that idea
okay I gotta
I got you baby I got to number forget
you get you
and so I'm gonna give up the double
yes
[Music]
whoa
I did it oh hi just tragic enough for
you to kill again good job by the way
make it this far so bug let's go there
because then I finally think we have
enough troops to it'd be
what
[Music]
Oh
they kind of here - I remember care we
need college you are no longer willing
to get regarding annuity
for now we are the most feared army in
the world
I don't know who's gonna what
ah hey I Who am I to question all right
let me see if there's anything at the
end of the comics or the credits
[Music]
all they thanks me that was awesome
thank you for thanking me I'm happy to
play it I played it I did I did a thing
[Music]
okay anything at the end maybe a little
bit of a secret nope okay all right that
is all there is
okay so that was Spooky's House of
jump-scares thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you for watching
throughout the entire playthrough this
game I actually didn't think that I
would get all the way to the end but
there you have it there it is it was
really really good it was a unique take
on horror that really scared me a lot of
times throughout it sorry my voice is
kind of going been recording a lot in
preparation for VidCon so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for sticking through this let me know
what you thought of this and the ending
in the comments down below admittedly
I'm not terribly surprised I was more
surprised that it was a battle at the
end of the game so thank you again
everybody maybe there's an Easter Egg I
missed so you can play for yourself and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye but it's okay
[Music]